hey guys
welcome to automation anywhere full
course in this full course we will cover
the core topics of automation anywhere
automation anywhere is well known
robotic process automation tool
it has grown in popularity over the
years and is now used by organizations
all over the world
automation anywhere enables it
departments to set up software robots
that collect and interpret data in
various applications
assisting businesses in successfully
automating their business operations
here is the list of topics covered in
the automation anywhere full course
we'll first begin with what is rpa
then we look at the 10 reasons to learn
rpa
followed by which we will see some of
the real-time rpa examples
proceeding further we will see
installation of automation anywhere
and automation anywhere tutorial
we will see how excel operations are
performed in automation anywhere
proceeding further we will see some of
the important interview questions
that will help you crack automation
anywhere interview
proceeding further we will see rpa
developers salaries
and finally how to become an rpa
developer
i am sure you are excited to get started
with the automation anywhere full course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and click down the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
with automation anywhere full course
this is jim
he is an accountant in a multinational
company he handles several invoices and
other financial records like monetary
transactions
liabilities checks and ledgers on a
daily basis
one of his tasks is to copy all the
relevant information from these invoices
such as the name of the company invoice
id and data processing into a
spreadsheet
and mail the sheet along with other
financial reports to his superiors by
the end of the day
as any prompt employee he transfers all
the information to the sheet
attaches the reports and sends them over
to his boss
via email every day but over a period
he starts finding this task to be time
consuming and repetitive
frustrated jim looks for a way to reduce
the time and effort
it takes to complete the task and voila
he stumbles across robotic process
automation aka
rpa using robotic process automation he
builds a simple bot that extracts
information from several invoices into
an excel sheet
attaches all the necessary financial
reports and sends them over to his
superiors via email
at a specific time every day so
what exactly is robotic process
automation
robotic process automation rpa is the
use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities
to handle high volume repetitive tasks
that previously required humans to
perform
some of these tasks include addressing
queries making calculations
maintenance of records and performing
transactions
there are several misconceptions about
rpa
rpa is not a humanoid robot it does not
have a physical form
and no resemblance to humans rpa cannot
replace humans or replicate human
cognitive functions
it does not have a brain of its own and
cannot perform
logical or critical thinking as humans
do
the working of rpa includes four crucial
phases
1. the planning phase typically involves
gathering the processes to be automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
2. the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed plan
three deployment and testing is a vital
phase
since it uncovers any unexpected outages
and ensures a bug-free product
four lastly there's the support and
maintenance phase
which ensures that the product is
continuously updated
with smooth deployment across the user
base to meet the objectives of rpa
tools are used these rpa tools are
software applications that can configure
tasks
and automate them some of the popular
rpa tools in the market
are uipath automation anywhere blue
prism
work fusion pega and redwood among
others
when it comes to quality rpa ensures
consistent error-free output
leading to reduced operational risks
this in turn
improves customer satisfaction in the
area of delivery
rpa can help decrease the average
handling time and this enhances the
customer experience
and ensures 24 7 business continuity
with respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65 percent through rpa
it offers a higher roi by driving
positive returns within quarters as
opposed
to years other advantages of rpa include
reduced training costs
minimal utilization of i.t resources and
easier software migration today many
domains and industries like banking and
finance
i.t integration processes human
resources
insurance agencies marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
readily deploy rpa rpa service adoption
has been showing tremendous growth since
2016. and
will continue to increase beyond 2020.
according to mckenzie's research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025. it
will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers
which constitute nine percent of the
global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with rpa adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now that we've discussed what rpa is and
isn't
here's a question for you which of the
following is not
an rpa use case email query processing
two data extraction three
image recognition four payroll
processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below
rpa offers the ability to automate
business processes
quickly and easily it pays the way for
digital transformation
by placing automation tools at the
user's disposal
so what are you waiting for get
certified
and become an rpa developer to build a
bright future in the field of automation
now let's jump into the topic 10 reasons
why you should learn rpa
but before jumping into it let me give
you a brief insight into what exactly
rpa is now do you remember the time you
used the digital calculator
in maybe your calculus class it made it
so much
easier for you to arrive at an answer
calculators undoubtedly helped you solve
complex mathematical problems
which previously required a lot of time
and of course doing manual calculations
have inherently
several errors but does calculation
account for automation well no
a conventional calculator requires
manual input
so this is partial automation automating
the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what rpa does
so what exactly is rpa
robotic process automation is the use of
software
with artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities
to handle high volume repeated tasks
that previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries
making calculations maintaining records
or even making transactions
so why is rpa gaining popularity so
rapidly
and why do companies and techies have
rpa perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn rpa
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry bots up and
running
goes quickly implementing a new rpa
software system
certainly happens much faster than
training a new person
you can have these data entry bots up
and running in just
days in contrast if you wanted to hire a
new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time in sorting out resumes conducting
interviews
going through the entire boring hiring
process and then finally when you find
the right person
you'd have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of rpa all of this is
countered
and number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the bots
need to learn something new
you can either replace them with new
bots or alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks
in terms of costs training an employee
for a new task will pan
out to be way more expensive and time
consuming
next up the bots will never quit now
with
rpa you don't have to worry about
employees quitting or dealing with the
turnover
bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is
or how repeatedly they're doing the same
tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the bots
got tired
software bots can work all the time 24
hours a day
every single day of the year at 100
capacity
now rpa doesn't take holidays it doesn't
have sick needs
and of course they do not have
unproductive days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal i.t resources
maintaining software
bots requires minimal i.t resources in
some cases
it doesn't id doesn't need to get
involved at all
your rpa systems will be managed by the
software provider
they're responsible for maintenance and
updates all of that
it completely takes the burden off it
and saves your company a whole lot of
money
roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains many of
these
organizations do not know how they
should determine their roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation
roi is visible it defines a clearer path
to demonstrate its
returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown
so has the time required to build
various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal for solution
to solve these types of problems the
system stores the information and it can
also remember and transform this
information very easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration now it's a fact that
software migrations are time consuming
and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost
could turn out to be tens or thousands
of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times
certain features and functionalities
which may have functioned in a
particular way in a previous
version may not even be present in the
updated version
so rpa helps with data migration with
accuracy
speed and continuous updating of
software
rpa has a free tier many rpa vendors
offer free tiers some of these vendors
are blue prism
automation anywhere ui path among others
these rpa software vendors are offering
high
rpa software notably ui path with their
community edition
and workfusion with their rpa express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replace now
rpa doesn't jeopardize an employee's job
but helps with the growth of new jobs
to do your work you need some additional
software yes
and virtual machines to deploy fully
independent digital bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
rpa could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result rpa does not pull down your
existing systems
but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to glassdoor the average
salary of an rpa developer in the u.s
is 77 000 us dollars and in
india the beginning salary for an rpa
developer
is around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like dell ibm
accenture
capgemini cognizant among others are
readily hiring rpa developers now with
that
let's move on to the growth projections
of rpa
now looking at the graph here both rps
software and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to mckenzie research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars
by the year 2025. it will touch more
than 230 million knowledge workers
which are which constitute about nine
percent of the global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing
high volume high transaction functions
will boost their capabilities and save
money
and time with rpa
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn rpa
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
rpa developers are responsible for the
creation
design development and implementation of
rpa systems
an rpa developer is expected to provide
guidance with process design
design develop test automation flip
workflows
deploy rpa components be it bots robots
or development tools
support the implementation of rpa
solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the automation
so moving to the most exciting part here
is an easy question for you to answer
which of the following is not an rpa use
case
option a email query processing
b data transfer between systems
c payroll processing or d
image recognition so make sure to leave
your answers in the comments section
or the chat section alright then
moving on so you must be wondering how
simply learn can help you
now if you're looking to make a career
as an rpa developer
then i'd recommend you go through some
of the course courses offered by us
so you could visit our official website
say simplylearn.com
and say rpa
you get a few options and depending on
your requirement
you can take up the appropriate course
so we have rpa training using uipath
all right so you can click on that and
get a brief overview of it
so this certification training is
designed to help you master rpa
processes and best practices
now this mainly focuses on ui path
certification
it also gives you an insight into the
key features
you can opt for your required training
options
and then you have a course curriculum
and then you have eligibility
so this training is ideal for anyone
with a technical background
and anybody who wants to kick start a
career in this field
so professionals can also benefit from
this training
and be developers project managers
architects or product managers
next up we have introduction to robotic
process automation
now then again you can look at the key
features what it provides
you have different courses for
individuals and businesses
you can go through the description and
if you think this suits your
requirements and you can opt this
and again it gives you the course
overview
if this is what you want to learn then i
think this course
is for you and lastly we have
automation anywhere certified advanced
rpa training course
now this is for automation anywhere
certification
so anybody looking for that should
totally go for this
we again have the overview here the key
salient features
we have training options and then the
criteria and course content
so you could go go ahead and look at
this
and then choose the appropriate one in
this video
we will be looking at the robotic
process automation example let us
consider a discussion between john and
jamie
john is very curious and wants to know
how and where rpa is used in different
fields
jaime being a developer helps john in
understanding the rpa examples
even if you are curious to know the
applications of rpa
then you're at the right place so let's
get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement a
customer representative
must understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data
sometimes asking for information that
has already been requested
this tends to decrease customer
satisfaction and extends call duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing rpa solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems
the customer service representative can
launch a bot
the bot completes all actions in seconds
with the press of a button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created
a customer service representative will
fill out the necessary information
to receive the queries and bots will use
that data
in multiple systems to complete the
transaction
let's look at an example consider a
scenario
where a company was providing support to
the client and the company
was supposed to handle a large number of
calls
approximately 20 000 calls per month
which required a significant amount of
time spent in the support team
because of the system's complexity an
executive's average time was about 10
minutes
the system was inefficient and slow
resulting in the poor customer service
with the rpa solution the organization
gained a virtual team
that can complete the task in less than
a minute resulting in a drastic
reduction in
an execution time the rpa board performs
the following task
loading a comprehensive customer profile
obtaining a detailed billing information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated
resolving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
financial service
financial service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments
and storing the records in a system data
is manually extracted from a bank
statements
to reconcile documents and link them to
its forms using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
excel legacy software
and manual labor which is tedious and
time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds
prompting clients to pay more quickly
rpa
in financial services tracks and
standardizes
and validates payments process orders
and avoids errors
and is always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant
makes the customers experience less
stressful adding value to the service
provider
rpa in finance eliminates the need for
endless email correspondence
and ensures a smooth payment approval
process matches invoices
to responsible parties and sets deadline
reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process
and relieves human employees of huge
tasks this enables precise and
structured
invoice processing consider a financial
service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently
and accurately in order to generate
ratings
using rpa company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data
this enabled enable decline to quickly
and cost effectively automate
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
financial service are
investment management reconciliation of
bank statements
organizing the finances record of
accounts receivables and pay
the third example is hr service this
operation
includes numerous routine steps such as
interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding
pairing and firing place a significant
burden on hr
and other support functions such as i.t
security
and facilities management particularly
for medium and large businesses
while it is expensive to build a
solution that encompasses
all of these functions and completes the
necessary tasks for new or departing
employees
some employees can be sloppy with
recording absences vacation or
in general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is rpa
can be used to collect and screen
resumes
and online application forms contact
through background checks
and compare the information to all the
relevant job requisitions
this allows the best candidates to be
shortlisted
rpa can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees
that are both personalized and accurate
and also validate records
by cross-checking data such as absentees
reports
against time logged in the corporate
network and alerting when information is
missing or inconsistent
talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees previously the
onboarding paperwork was completed
manually
by one person consuming a significant
amount of employees time
that could have been spent on more
valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day
the company understands that an hr
department wants to provide a digital
and straightforward experience the task
required a lot of copy and paste
activities with the implementation of
rpa
the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time
allowing hrs to spend more time on
corporate social responsibilities
hiring talent initiatives and improving
a company's reputation
the tasks performed by rpa bots in hr
service are
screening resumes onboarding of new
hires
attendance management induction and
training
employment management and survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
service delivery
thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies
looking to improve their customer
service high reliability and accuracy of
process outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
automation in telecom
reduces error rates to close to zero
improves data quality
improves customer service and increases
operational efficiency
all while contributing significantly to
cost reduction
rpa technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees based on the
employee section
a well-structured workflow can be
generated which serves as the foundation
for automated process
by mapping each process step with its
significant cost for manual execution
it is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and media company
decided to automate its order creation
and service removal process
to cut costs associated with the company
speed booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of rpa it
becomes simple
to automate the order build process and
service removal activity
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
telecom service are
it checks on the credit and sim card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints
porting customer phone numbers
responding to questions
from partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
healthcare systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation
such as claim management this results in
high operational cost
and slow process every industry has
inefficiencies
but few face the health care industry's
challenges
strict regulations regarding patient
data and lack of resources
to deal with such rules building takes
time after a health care service is
provided due to manual and repetitive
task in the management process
management process include document and
data input processing
and evaluation in addition to the
automating time consuming task
patients can schedule appointments
without the intervention of hospital
employees
credit to rpa technology along with
eliminating the need of resource
allocation for scheduling
by allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly
this application can improve customer
relations rpa allows healthcare
providers to track and document each
process step
in structured log files to comply with
external audits
rpa improves data confidentiality
because boards handle this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization
deals with the process of patient
transaction data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process
and data reconciliation for healthcare
schemes are some of the manual process
they must streamline daily
the primary goal was to increase the
efficiency of existing approaches
to achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented and the most significant
possible impact was obtained
rpa platform handled claims processing
and health data reconciliation program
healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
healthcare service are
appointment scheduling regulatory
compliance
data entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment
in this video we will learn about
installation of automation anywhere
community edition
prerequisite enterprise control room
requires a server level machine to be
installed the server can be a physical
machine in your data center
or a cloud platform instance cloud
platforms like
amazon web services google cloud
platform
and microsoft azure the device should
have a processor of
8 core intel xeon processor
it should have storage disk space of
at least 500 gb and
network of 1 gigabit ethernet
it is recommended that you configure the
enterprise control room network
bandwidth to be greater than one
gigabyte ethernet
because uplink traffic can quickly
exceed one gigabit ethernet
depending on the complexity of the
automation run
operating system automation anywhere is
compatible with the operating system
such as windows 10
windows server 2012 windows server 2016
and windows server 2019. automation
anywhere
supports both 32-bit and 64-bit
operating system versions
finally the system should have a ram of
16 gb
let's look at the features of the
community edition
students and developers can use the
automation 360 cloud platform for free
with the community edition
it is completely web-based you can build
a rpa bot in the cloud from any device
thanks to a completely web-based
experience that requires no download
utilize the cloud to gain access to
cutting-edge enterprise class technology
the most recent enterprise class
technology
community edition will allow you to stay
up to date with the latest version
of our enterprise platform ai drag and
drop
with direct iqbot integration you can
automate your document centric process
drag and drop simplicity with instance
on ease of use
create bots at any skill level create
bots using no code
low code or bring your own code options
begin by using free bots use free build
boards for personal productivity
business continuity and other purposes
let's look at the installation of
community edition
let's go to the browser go to the
automation anywhere official website
automation anywhere.com
after going to the website scroll down
here you can see community edition click
on community edition
to download the community edition free
fill out the form
fill all the necessary details and click
on get free community edition
you fill in all the details and click on
get free community edition
you will receive an email so you will
receive an email
the email consists of a control room url
a username and password
so open this control room url
once you click on the control room link
a username password a login page appears
where you need to enter the username and
password so enter the username and
password
which you have received in the mail and
login
unlike other additions in community
edition there will be no client
option you can develop the bots on the
cloud
let us build our first bot let us go to
the control room
so we'll build our first bot so the
first step
under the robotic process automation
click on create a bot
so enter the name say first bot
enter the name and click on create and
edit
so you can see the first bot is
successfully created
now search for the message box here
double click on the message box to add
it in the workflow
so enter the message here enter the
message which you want to be displayed
so let us enter say
hello how are you so we have entered
this message
after entering the message click on save
button
and after saving click on run
it's downloading the dependencies
here you can see the message has been
displayed hello how are you
when when you do it for the first time
when you click on the run button
a pop-up will appear to connect to my
computer
then the file will get downloaded the
file is to install a bot agent
the bot will get connected to the
control room then there will be an
option to enable extension to the chrome
after doing all that finally
finally the bot is ready to display the
message
so here you can see the message has been
displayed
in this session we will learn about
automation anywhere tutorial
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a well-known
robotic process automation tool
that enables business to automate
end-to-end business operations
automation anywhere provides powerful
and user-friendly rpa capabilities
such as cloud native web-based
intelligent automation solution
for automating any complex task
it is a web-based management system that
employs a control room to execute
automated tasks
it improves the efficiency of business
process and reduces the need for human
labor
features of automation anywhere
automation anywhere offers an easy to
use interface
for building boards and designing
business process automation workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as windows
linux and mac os
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms
including microsoft windows citrix web
and sap it consists of different bot
views for collaboration
flow view for business users list view
for developers
and dual view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like
javascript python and vbscript
as well as advanced variable
capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture
that allows for the addition of new
command packages
let's look at the automation anywhere
components
the first component is automation
anywhere robotic interface
aari it is a user-friendly interface
that allows business users to
collaborate with bots
users can initiate process automation
provide feedback
to the bots in order for process to be
resumed
and escalate requests to additional
users for downstream processing
aari that is automation anywhere robotic
interface
enables enterprises to unlock previously
unavailable automation opportunities
between humans and the bots
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution
capable of reading and processing a wide
range of
complex documents and emails iqbot
intelligently captures classifies and
extracts semi-structured
and unstructured data using rpa and
multiple eai techniques
document centric business process to be
automated end to end
what inside the analytics platform that
delivers real-time
interactive and intelligent insights
into business process
and operational intelligence bot insight
takes the large amount of content level
and productivity data generated by
deployed bots
and converts it into insights via
automatically generated
and customizable dashboards
discovery bot an intelligent business
solution for
enterprise business that enables end
users to discover automation
opportunities
through process discovery discovery
board focuses on process automation
by capturing document process
identifying opportunities from business
centric process
and pre-authorizing opportunities based
on roi
and create bots automatically discovery
bot
collaborates with business workers to
identify automation opportunities
that can maximize the return on your rpa
investment
let's look at the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed
architecture
the enterprise control room a web-based
platform
that manages the development and
execution of digital workforce
provides centralized management bot
creators and
bot runners are linked to the enterprise
control room
bot creators are software development
platforms
for authorizing and customizing
automations
bot runners a runtime system deployed on
the machine that carry out the
automations
bot runners can be installed on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
let's explore the architecture in detail
what creators a bot is a self-contained
task that requires little to no
human intervention to complete the bot
creator
is a customized development client for
automation anywhere that is used to
create bots
task editor event watcher bot player
auto login and local scheduler are all
included
the bot creator also includes the
ability
to create boards from a device utilizing
the enterprise client application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room
after the bot creator user signs in for
the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
bot runners a bot trainer has the
ability to run
bots from a device utilizing the
enterprise client application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room
after the bot runner users log in for
the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
ports are run by the bot runner which is
a software machine
bot runners can run bots at scale after
they have been developed with bot create
control room the enterprise control room
serves as a single point of management
for all bots
enterprise control room is placed on a
server in the data center
and configured to work with the other
data center components
a river proxy is in charge of listening
for request for remote connections
and sending them to the appropriate
specialized service
using a collection of specialized web
service the enterprise control room
manages schedules executes and
configures various bots
and bot runner capabilities
let's look at the types of bots in
automation anywhere
task bot task bots are used for
automating repetitive tasks
based on the rules these tasks are
simple to create and can reliably
complete multi-step procedures
document administration claims
management
hr departments i.t and other areas
benefit from task bots
they increase production reduce errors
and save money
metabot metabots are more advanced
version
of taskbots metabots are automation
building components
that help with next generation
integration scalability
these are intended for scalable complex
process
on a computer metabots are used to
automate applications
application apis visual captures
and integration flow can all be used to
develop meta bots
iqbot iq bots are the next generation of
intelligent bots with the ability to
think like humans
these boards are designed to learn on
their own and carry out tasks in
accordance with that learning
users can experience the potential of
automation with iq bots
which use advanced cognitive technology
and advanced artificial technologies
these boards have
capabilities such as self-learning
decision making
and subject matter expertise among
others
data can be extracted from
semi-structured and unstructured data
by these bots iq bots also learn to
recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
with each human confirmation it learns
and improves its ability
to carry out the act benefits of using
automation anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users
of varying skill levels to easily use
the product
and accelerate the learning process with
instant web-based deployment
you can get started with writing bots
right away
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device
anywhere it provides continuity of
operations
with high availability and disaster
recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure
investment it gives low cost maintenance
a unified platform for front office back
office
and employee applications is provided
let's look at the demo so let's see a
demo
in this demo we'll create a board which
will automatically
login inside the simply learn login page
so i'll show you
let's go to the browser i'll go to the
simply learns
page
so this is the simply launch login page
so in this page the bot will
automatically enter the email address
password and it will click on the login
button
and it will take you inside the simply
lens page
so we'll create a bot so
i'll show you how the bot works so i
have created it
let's see the output first and then
we'll get started with the
project so i'll click on the run button
it will download all the dependencies
here you can see it's entering the email
address
it's entering the password and it will
click on the login button
so this is the project this is the
output
so you have seen the output so let's get
started
we'll close this go to the go to the
mail which you received from the
automation anywhere and click on the
control room link
and you will open up here after coming
here
click on create a bot
so enter a name
let's say we'll enter as login bot since
we are
creating a project to login
if you want you can give the description
and next click on create and edit
there are three options here flow list
and dual
in the flow it only shows the flow chart
of what activities or actions
you are dragging and dropping it in the
list it shows the
in the form of the list all the actions
and in the dual
it shows the flowchart as well as the
actions
what actions it is performing
so first we need the browser option so
we'll search for the browser action
so this is the browser action so the
browser package
contains actions that enable you to
download file find broken lines
and launch a website so this package
basically supports internet explorer
microsoft edge and google chrome
browsers
so the browser package includes the
actions like close
download file get source code find
broken lines go back
open run javascript now for us to open
the browser
to open the simply learns website we
need the open option
so let's click on the open double click
on the open
so what open does is opens the browser
to a specific webpage
whichever web page link we provides it
opens that browser so what we want to
open
do we want to open it in the existing
tab or a new tab
or a new window so in existing tab it
opens the web page in the currently open
tab
so this existing tab option is only
available in the google chrome browser
and new tab opens the web page in a new
tab like select the tab from the list of
the active tabs in the google chrome
browser or insert a new window variable
and in the new window this opens a
webpage in the new window or
offer specific browser whichever browser
you choose it opens a webpage in a new
window
so all these options are applicable in
the google chrome
browser so we will select the new window
option
and the browser okay you have these
options
internet explorer mozilla firefox chrome
and microsoft edge
so we will select google chrome and
we'll select the link to open
so we should select the link so we'll go
to the simplylands website page
so this is the page we are logging in so
that is why we need the
link of this page so copy the link of
this page
and paste the link here
and we need it in the new window so
save it
and let's run and see if this opens
in the new window let's click on run
okay so till now we are going right so
we have entered the link and we have run
the bot and
the bot is opening the web page in the
new window
so we'll close this so after this
we need the recorder package so search
for the recorder package
so this is the recorder package in this
we have the capture action
so the capture action from the recorder
package is used to capture an
interaction with the user interface
object such as a text box
button table menu radio button
combo box check box list view link
tree and package tab the capture action
enables you to add single interaction
when building your bot
so let's double click on capture option
so let's select dual so that we can see
what action it
triggers
so after selecting the capture option
so select the browser option browser
window then
click on this refresh windows
so it will show a list of
so it will show the list of pages that
are open in the browser
so scroll down we need
learning on simply so this is the
webpage
in which we are logging in so select the
web page
go down and let's click on capture
object
click on capture object so first we need
to fill in the email address
so you can see here it's showing a red
color box
so click on email address
so it will capture this object of email
address
here you can see recording capture
finalization
so the object is captured
scroll down and here you can see action
to take on
object what action should be taken on
the object which we have selected
so we need to enter the text
that is the email address so select set
text
and scroll down and enter what text you
want to
enter that so i'll enter my email id
now scroll down
you can enter the time how much ever you
want
it is recommended to enter a 9 seconds
or 10 seconds
but it's optional so we'll skip it for
now
you can see here it's the of the type
user login
page so we have captured the first
object
that is email address so we'll save it
and we'll run and see if it's entering
the email address
here you can see it's open the web page
in the new window
and it has entered the email address
so let's go back to the control room
close this
your bot has run successfully so now
that we have
entered the email address we need to
enter the password
so we will use another capture
action
and this will will select the same
browser window
and will select the same
learning on simply learn website
and we'll click on capture object but
now this time
we'll capture the object password
select the password object
and recording capture finalization
so now that the object is captured we
need to
select the action what action should be
performed
so we will select set text
now that we have selected text since we
are entering the password
the password should be credential and
when the password is credentialed you
can't enter the password here you need
to
pick the password you need to pick the
password from the locker room
so now that note that i have already
created a credential
and entered in the locker room for me
it's showing here
i'll show you how to create a credential
and create a
locker room so we'll save it till here
for now
we'll save here
let's go to the credentials section here
if you go
in the manage options you can see
credentials
so go in the credentials
this is the credentials which i have
already created
go to the create credential options
click on it
so enter the credential name
say i'll enter it as username
enter the description if you want any
and scroll down
and enter the attribute name what
attribute are you entering
for first we will enter the email
address
so select
email address and
select the input type as standard
description is optional
and enter the value what is the email
address so i'll enter my email address
scroll down and click on the plus here
to add
so there are two attributes in the login
page right that is the email address and
password
so one attribute we have entered the
email address and the
other attribute is the password
attribute so select password
and input type as standard and since we
are entering the password it should be
masked
so that no one could see your password
the password should
be encrypted so enter your password here
after entering the password
so you have created the you have filled
all the credential details
click on create credential so after
clicking on create credential
your credential will be created
so that is how you create a credential
after creating the credential
so since i have already created a
credential i'll click on cancel
before creating if you want to create
the credential enter all these details
and click on the create
page so i'll click on cancel so
this is once you create the credential
you can see
like this a credential whatever you have
created it will be shown here
so this is how you create a credential
now after creating the credential you
need to
go to the locker section and here you
can see
create a locker click on create a locker
so enter the locker room whatever you
want
so let us enter username
after entering the locker room go to the
credential
and select the credential whatever you
have created
since i have already entered the
credential in the locker
that is why it is that is why this is
disabled for me
so when you are entering the credential
in the locker room for the first time
can come inside the locker and select
this option
check this option and click on this so
this will get
this will get deposited in the locker
this owners and managers
section is disabled the community
edition
so we can't do any changes in that this
will also be disabled
this will also be disabled go to the
consumers
so enable this enable this click on
the community edition user and
get deposit this in the locker click on
this
then scroll down so this is the last
then when you go back scroll up when you
finish doing all this
this create locker option will get
enabled
so when this option get enabled click on
create locker and your locker will be
created
that's how you create a blocker since i
have already created a locker
i did not so this options are not
enabled for me
so this option is also not enabled when
you do all these steps
this option gets enabled that is how you
create a locker
i hope you have understood how to create
a credential and
how to create a locker so let's go back
to the bot which we had created let's go
to the automation
so the bot which we had created was a
login bot
so we had selected the recorder option
in this recorder we had selected the
action
password so we need to enter the
password
so select here go to here
click on pick and select the locker
which we had created
the email address
select the credential that is the email
address credential
select the attribute attribute is the
password attribute we had entered two
attributes right one is the email
address and the password
so we are entering the password here
select the
password attribute and click on confirm
scroll down
here you can see we have picked the
password
if you want you can enter the time which
is optional
you can see it is of the type user
password
so that's all save it now we need a
one more recorder action that is to
click on the
login button so we'll select for the
search for the recorder select the
capture option
and we'll select the browser
select the web page and click on the
capture object
so the object which we are capturing now
is the
login button so click on the login
button
here you can see recording capture
finalization
so the login button is being captured so
what action should be
taken
so we need to click on the login button
here you can see
if you have noticed there is no option
to set text
why because this is a login button when
we can't enter the text here so that
option is
not here so from this options
we should select the click option to
login
so we'll select the click option
and you can see here it is of the type
login
button login so we have selected the
login button
now we'll save it
so we have completed the project in the
first step we have selected the browser
package in browser package we have
selected the open
action which opens the web page the link
page we have provided it opens the
webpage
in the second we have selected from the
recorder package we have selected the
capture option
in which we have captured the email
address then we have captured the
password
and then we have captured to click on
the login button
so let's save it we have saved it so
let's click on
run and see
here you can see the webpage has opened
in the new window
email address has been entered
password has been entered and it is
clicking on the login page
and it is redirecting to the website
and here you can see the login but login
page has been
open so your what has run successfully
in this video we will learn about
automation anywhere excel operations
excel packages the excel package
consists of
actions that allow us to automate many
of the tedious tasks
while working with microsoft excel
spreadsheets
the excel packages that automation
anywhere offers
are excel advanced package to use the
excel advance package command
we must first install the excel advanced
package it's utilized to automate
actions
involving the workbook worksheet rows
columns and cells
the system must have microsoft office
installed
the versions of microsoft office that
are supported range from
microsoft office 2016 to 2090.
file formats like dot xls dot xlsx
are supported by this command and it
also supports the older excel formats
as well as the advanced excel actions
and it requires the installation of the
microsoft excel application
next we have excel basic package this
package
enables quick spreadsheet activities for
dot xlsx files
without requiring the ms excel software
to be installed
office 365 excel this package provides
commands for working with excel online
the office 365 xl bundle includes
actions
that allow you to automate operations in
microsoft excel online
if you are using microsoft excel 365 via
a web browser
you can use the office 365 excel package
to automate excel process
let's look at the excel commands some of
the excel commands are
open spreadsheet this allows to open the
excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened
using the open spreadsheet operation the
excel command
identifies the spreadsheet using the
same session name as one used in the
open spreadsheet operation
save spreadsheet this command saves a
spreadsheet in an open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index
or sheet by name get cell
this command allows to retrieve the
values of a specific cell as well as
the range of the cell set cell
this command sets the value of the
active cell or specific cell in an excel
spreadsheet
you can assign a variable to the cell
value
go to cell moves to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet
it can move one cell to the left or to
the right of the active cell
and it can move one cell above or below
the active cell
or move to the beginning or end of the
column
delete cell this command deletes the
value in an active cell or in a specific
cell within an excel spreadsheet
run excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an excel spreadsheet
enter the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments
let's look at the demo in this demo we
will have two excel files
and we will use excel operations and
merge these two excel files
so let's jump into automation anywhere
so what we are doing is we have two
excel files i'll show you the files
so this is excel file one which has
which has a data table of employees and
salaries
and we have another file excel file two
which has the data table of employee
names and salads
so the file one has different names
employee names and different salaries
and the file to have different names and
different salaries
so we will combine both of this data
table we'll create a bot which will
combine both of this data table
so let's go to the control room
go to the automation section and click
on create
new bot name the bot
we'll name it as excel bot
click on create and edit
so after creating a bot go to search
actions
and search for a step
step action and double click on this so
what step action does is
it runs a sequence of commands for
example
to open a file 1 and file 2 there is a
sequence of steps
and at the end of this project there
will be many list of steps
so which will be confusing so just to
avoid confusion
we will drag and drop this step and
inside each step
there will be a number of actions
so we have now that we have selected
this action step
give the title uh we'll name it as file
1
so go to excel packet search for excel
so in excel advanced
since i have ms excel installed in my pc
so
i will use excel advanced scroll down
and select open open action opens an
excel spreadsheet
this action works with xlsx and xls
and all these files which you can see
here
so now after dragging and dropping open
option
you can select the file path from
control room desktop file or a variable
i have the file on my desktop so i'll
select desktop
and i'll browse
so i'll select the file that is file 1
and i'll open so i have selected the
file
and our file contains the headers so
check this box
and check this specific sheet name so
that you can name the sheet
so our data table is in the sheet one
so type the name of the sheet and open
in
read write mode or read only mode so we
will open in read
write more and if you scroll down there
is session name
so we'll keep it as default
so this much is done next activity
so this action should be inside the step
action so drag and drop it inside okay
next we need get multiple cells
double click on get multiple cells get
multiple
cells retrieve the values of multiple
cells in an excel worksheet
so you can select range of cells to be
returned
all rows or specific rows or cell range
we we will select all rows since we want
to merge
all the rows so select all rows
and select the read visible texting cell
or read cell value
select any one of this and the session
name keep it as default
and you need to assign value to the
variable so we'll create a variable
since we are using the data table we
will name it as table1
okay let's create and select
so we have selected the variable and now
we need to close the file
so we'll select the close action
so the close action closes an excel
spreadsheet
so double click and select the
close option here you can you should
uncheck the save changes when closing
the file
and name the session as default
okay so step one that is file one
so these three steps so this is done for
file one now we need to repeat this for
file two as well
so we'll save here till now what we have
done
okay i will repeat this for file two
let's drag and drop step
action
so in step two name it as file two
we are performing this step for file two
okay
now we will go to excel package
and select open we need to open the file
so basically we are repeating this above
steps and we will select the file too
we'll go to desktop file browse and
select file to
so we have selected the file too and
this file also contains
headers check this box and specify the
sheet name
as 1 we have the data table in sheet 1
so sheet 1
and read and write mode and session name
since the session name for the file 1 is
default
and we need to change here so we'll give
it as default 2
as the session so this much is done
now next we need get multiple cells
so double click on get multiple cells
will select all rows and change the
session name to default to
and create a variable here so right
click and create a variable
name it as table2
and create and select okay this is done
next we need to close the file so
scroll up and select the close action
and change the session name for file two
we have kept the session name as
default two so we'll use the same
session okay so this much
is done we will save
okay now file one and file two is
created
so this actions are outside the file of
two outside is step five two so we'll
bring it inside
these are supposed to be inside
okay now step one and step two is done
next we need to merge this file so go to
the data table package
so in this data table package you can
see all these actions
we need the merge action this merges two
data table together in a single data
table
so double click on merge data table
okay so after double clicking on merge
data table
enter the first table name so we
enter the data table name we'll select
it as table 1
what we had created in step 1 file 1 and
similarly we'll enter the second data
table name
so these are basically the two data
tables which we want to merge
right then enter the name of the data
table in which we want to merge
so we want to merge it in either we can
merge it in the
file one or file two but we will create
a new file and merge it in the
new file so we'll create a new variable
here
and we'll name it as table three
okay so create and select so new data
table is created
to create a new file to write it in a
new file there is an
action here right to file this writes a
data table into a specified file
so select this and choose a variable
that is
table 3 variable and enter the file
so to enter the file name select the
file path where you want to create this
file
so i'll select the file path of my
desktop and from the desktop
i want to create a file as name result
file
result.csv so i've created this file
so to create this file you need to check
this box create folders and file if
it doesn't exist so this file doesn't
exist
i've just named it here now well i check
this box
so this file will get created and check
this
overwrite existing file so that when you
run it for a second time or third time
the data doesn't overlap so every time
you run it a new data has been
overwritten
so check this box and you can change
this if you want row delimiter to new
line
or column delimiter comma and all this
okay so this is done
let's save
and let's run
it is downloading the dependencies it
will take a few seconds
or sometimes a few minutes let's wait
so your bot has run successfully we will
go to the desktop and check
the file which we create here you can
see the result file is created
so we'll open this result file
so here you can see the result file
where both the tables have been
merged so from the row to tim
till the row seven this was in the file
one and this last five rows were in the
file two
so you can see here both the data tables
have been merged
now you can see here there that there
are rows repeated
this row john is repeated twice so
we don't want the rows to be repeated we
want to eliminate the rows which are
repeated so for that
let's go here so let's close this
and to remove the duplicate rows we have
an option here called
remove duplicate rows remove duplicate
rows
remove the duplicate rows from our data
table
double click on remove duplicate rows
and take it above right file
okay so in remove duplicate rows select
the data table name
we want to remove duplicators from table
3 which is the merge data table
so select the table 3 variable and now
let's save it
and let's run
okay your bot has run successfully now
we'll go and
check if the duplicate rows have been
removed
let's close this and go to the desktop
open the result file
and here you can see there are no
duplicators so there was an another
duplicate row here named john
and that row has been removed and there
are no duplicate rows left
that is how you remove the duplicate
rows now
let's see now we want this salaries to
be sorted we want this in order
the employee with the highest salary we
need him at the top
and the employee with the lowest salary
we need him at the bottom
so let's go to the control room
to sort the data there is an action
called sort
this sort action sorts a data table on
the basis of column by ascending or
descending order
so double click on this
double click on sort and drag and drop
the sort
action bring it above right file
so in sort data table enter the data
table name will enter the table 3
which is the merge data table and we can
sort by column name or column index will
sort it by name
and what is the column name which we are
sorting it is the
salaries call right so
let's type the column name salaries
make sure the spelling is right
otherwise it will show an error
next we need to select the order in
which we want to sort
we'll select the descending order
because we want the employee with the
highest salary at the top
so select the descending order and let's
save and let's click on run
oops there was an error maybe the error
is because i have kept the excel sheet
open
so i'll close the excel sheet and run
again
so here we go your bot has run
successfully let's go and
check if the data is sorted let's click
on the results
and here you can see the data has been
sorted in the
descending order the employee with the
highest salary is at the top
and it's decreasing in the order and the
employee with the lowest salary is at
the bottom
so we have performed this operation of
sorting data
let's go back to the control room let's
close this
there are similar other actions in the
data table
there is a sign or there is a sign
action
so assign action assigns the value of
the source table variable
to the destination table variable the
change column type where you can change
the type of the column
if it's an integer you can change it to
string and if it's in string you want to
change it to integer then you can use
this action
there is clear content there is clear
content action
clears all the content of specified data
table and get the number of rows
you can get the number of rows in this
get the number of rows
action and you can delete any column if
you want you can delete row
insert column insert row i have shown a
few actions here you can check out all
of these actions
and if you have any doubt regarding any
of these actions you can comment in the
comment section
and i'll try to answer so you can delete
column delete row
insert column or insert row similarly
you can join
join two data tables together as per the
column specified
as per inner joint outer joint full
joint however you want you can
join the data tables and the merge
action we have must do
two data tables here and you can remove
the duplicate rows
get the number of rows search for value
but search for any particular value if
you want
and search and you can set the value of
a single cell
and you can sort the data in ascending
or descending adder and write to the
file
so you can write the data to file
e so these are the actions present in
the data table
if you're planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or automation
enable developer role
here is a comprehensive list of most
frequently asked automation anywhere
interview questions with answers
we'll first look at the beginner level
questions
what is automation anywhere automation
anywhere is well-known robotic process
automation tool
that enables business to automate
end-to-end business operations
it provides powerful and user-friendly
rpa capabilities
such as cloud native web-based
intelligent automation solution
for automating any complex tasks it is a
web-based management system that employs
a control room to execute automated
tasks
it improves the efficiency of business
process and reduces the need for human
labor
what are the features of automation
anywhere automation anywhere offers an
easy to use interface
for building bots and designing business
process automation workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as windows
linux and mac os it consists of a
recorder that works on a variety of
platforms including microsoft windows
citrix web and sap it consists of
different bot views for collaboration
flow view for business users list view
for developers
and dual view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like javascript
python and vbscript as well as advanced
variable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture
that allows for the addition of new
command packages
what are the different components in
automation anywhere
automation anywhere robotic interface
aari
is a user friendly interface that allows
business users to collaborate with bots
aari enables enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities
between humans and bots that rpa could
not address
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution
capable of reading and processing a wide
range of complex documents and emails
iqbod intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured and
unstructured data using rpa
and multiple ai techniques allowing
document centric business process to be
automated end-to-end bot insight
the analytics platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into the business process
and operational intelligence
discovery bot an intelligent business
solution for enterprise business
that enables end users to discover
automation opportunities through process
discovery
discovery bot collaborates with business
workers to identify automation
opportunities
that can maximize the return on your rpa
investment
what is an enterprise control room and
how does it work
the enterprise control room serves as a
single point of management for all bots
the enterprise control room manages
schedules
executes and configures various bots and
bot runner capabilities
using a collection of specialized web
services
the enterprise control room is placed on
a server in the data center
and configured to work with the other
data center components
explain the different type of bots in
automation anywhere
task bot task boards are used for
automating repetitive tasks based on the
rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document administration claims
management
hr departments i.t and other areas
benefit from task bots
metabot metabots are more advanced
version of taskbots
metabots or automation building
components that help with next
generation integration scalability
these are intended for a scalable
complex process
on a computer meta bots are used to
automate applications
iqbot iqbots are the next generation of
intelligent bots
with the ability to think like humans
these bots are designed to learn on
their own
and carry out tasks in accordance with
that learning
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
with each human confirmation it learns
and improves its ability to carry out
the act
explain briefly the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the enterprise control room is a
web-based platform that manages the
development and execution of digital
workforce
and provides a centralized management
bot creators and bot runners are linked
to the enterprise control room
bot creators are software development
platforms for authorizing and
customizing automations
bot runners are runtime system deployed
on machines that carry out the
automations bot runners can be installed
on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
what is a bot creator a bot is a
self-contained task that requires little
to no human intervention to complete
the bot creator is a customized
development client for automation
anywhere that is used to create bots
task editor event watcher bot player
auto login
and local scheduler are all included the
bot creator also includes the ability to
create bots from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room after the bot
creator user
signs in for the first time and the user
can deploy bots on that device
what is a bot runner a bot runner has
ability to run boards from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application the device is registered
with the enterprise control room
after the bot runner user locks in for
the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
bots are run by bot runner which is a
software machine
bot runners can run bots at a scale
after they have been developed by the
bot creator
explain triggers in automation anywhere
triggers integrate predefined events
into your process
reducing the amount of tasks that users
must do repeatedly
in automation anywhere you can use
attendant automation to create unique
triggers for numerous apps
these triggers can then be used to
launch a bot
at triggers to have the bot execute
automatically whenever a specified event
occurs
for instance pressing a specific key or
series of key strokes
explain the benefits of automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of varying skill
levels
to easily use the product and accelerate
the learning process
with instant web-based deployment you
can get started with writing bots right
away
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device anywhere
it provides continuity of operations
with high availability and disaster
recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
a unified platform for front office back
office
and employee applications it gives lower
maintenance cost
what are bought insights the analytics
platform that delivers real-time
interactive and intelligent insights
into business process
and operational intelligence bot insight
takes a large amount of content level
and productivity data
generated by deployed bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable dashboards
what are the different excel packages
that automation anywhere offers
automation anywhere offers three
different excel packages
excel advanced package it's utilized to
automate actions
involving the workbook worksheet rows
columns and
cells the system must have microsoft
office installed
the versions of microsoft office that
are supported range from
2016 to microsoft office 2019.
excel basic package enables quick
spreadsheet activities
for dot xlsx files without requiring the
ms excel software to be
installed office 365 excel
it provides commands for working with
excel online
the office 365 excel bundle includes
actions that allow you to automate
operations
in microsoft excel online if you are
using microsoft excel 365 via
web browser you can use the office 365
excel package
to automate excel process let us look at
the intermediate level questions
explain functions of the following excel
commands
open spreadsheet allows to open the
excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened
save spreadsheet saves a spreadsheet in
an open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an
open workbook it specifies whether to
activate the sheet by index
or sheet by name
get cell allows to retrieve the values
of a specific cell
as well as the range of the cell set
cell
sets the value of the active cell or a
specific cell in an excel spreadsheet
you can assign a variable to the cell
value
go to cell move to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet
delete cell delete the value of a
specific cell within our excel
spreadsheet
run excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an excel spreadsheet
enter the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments
explain the types of triggers to start
abort
email in email trigger a bot is launched
when a new email message arrives in the
given email service
such as microsoft outlook email server
or ews server file and folder
when a predefined file or folder event
occurs it starts a bot
as the trigger you can choose from the
following options
like when you make a new file or a
folder or when a file or a folder that
already exists gets destroyed
or when you rename a file or a folder
the next type is hotkey when a
predetermined combination of keystrokes
is performed on the keyboard a bot is
launched
as the trigger you can use any
combination
like control alt windows
and escape are all control keys regular
alphabetical characters are used in the
key
interface when a predetermined event
occurs on the selected user
interface element abort is launched
some instances of pre-configured events
are a button is pressed by the user
or an application is opened or closed by
the user
a check box is selected or cleared by
the user
how to record the task with universal
recorder
step 1 create a new bot or open an
existing bot
then click on the start recording and
select universal recording
step 3 perform the required steps and
click on finish
step 4 edit the actions and click on
save
let's jump into the automation in our
control room and see how to record the
task with universal recorder
so here we are in the control room we
have created a new bot
so let's search for a message box
double click on the message box
enter a message
close message box after 5 seconds
now go to start recording or you can
press control
plus r click on start recording
and select the window which you want to
record
so i'll select the calculator
and click on universal recorder
and now you can perform actions
so i am adding the numbers
uh
so i have randomly performed some
actions now i'll click on finish
and let's finish the recording
now let us save and click on run
so here you can see the message is
displayed hello it will close in 5
seconds and it has closed
and the recording is been played and it
shows the actions which we have recorded
you can see your bot has run
successfully
how to clone a bot in automation
anywhere
create a read-only duplicate of the bot
in the private workspace from the public
workspace
so you can have a local copy without
checking it out
step one login to the control room as a
bot creator user
and then in public space click bots the
my bot page is displayed with the list
of folders or files containing the bot
then select the bot you want to clone
click the actions menu and click
clone task bot the clone bot appears in
the same folder structure in the private
workspace
so let's jump into the automation in our
control room
and see how to clone a bot
so this is the my bot folder so these
are the bots which i have created
so let's go to this python board select
this bot
and go to the options and click here
copy task bot and here you can see
a copy of that bot is been created and
name the bot
whatever you want so i'll keep the
default name python board copy one
and click on copy you can select the
folder where you want to store it
i have kept the default folders
and here you can see python bot copy one
has been successfully created
so that is how you clone a bot
explain the following commands delay
command weight command and
task command the delay command is used
to delay the execution of next command
for a set length of time you have the
option of specifying the time in
milliseconds or seconds
weight command the weight command is
used to add a condition
that forces the next set of actions to
wait for the contents
of a screen to change before proceeding
task command task command is used to
start a task
within a task or pause it and stop it
explain predefined variables in
automation anywhere
predefined variables are variables that
provide specific information about the
machine
on which the bot is run the values of a
preset variable
cannot be changed by users below are the
examples of predefined variables
clipboard date and time string
and system settings and parameters
explain the date time predefined
variables in automation anywhere
using the date time packages activities
you can manipulate date and time
variables
date returns a date that includes the
hours minutes and seconds
day the day is returned in date format
r is a function that returns the rs in
as format
machine the device name is returned as a
string by the machine
millisecond millisecond returns a value
between 0
and triple 9 milliseconds minute
the minutes are returned in minute
format month
month is a function that returns the
month in month format
seconds the seconds are returned in
seconds format
year returns the current year in the
year format
how are loops used to control a bot in
automation anywhere
loops are one of the most powerful board
building constructions
loops are the instructions that repeat a
set of actions a certain number of times
or until a condition is met
when a loop checks for the completion of
a defined number of iterations
or satisfaction of a condition if not
satisfied
the loop is executed the same conditions
are checked repeatedly
until the condition has been satisfied
if the condition is satisfied
then the loop is not being executed
explain error handling and automation
anywhere
error handling in automation anywhere
consists of the error handler package
that comprises actions that make it
simple to handle exceptions
that abort encounters and pass control
to the bot's other activities
you can use the error handler actions to
separate the actions that you can't use
to complete a task
from the actions or to handle an
exception
when a bot meets an error handling
exceptions ensure that the work is
complete
how is automation anywhere different
from uipath
on the basis of single integrated
automation platform
automation anywhere provides intelligent
automation platform like
attended automation unattended
automation intelligent document
processing
and many more whereas uipath requires
third party products and integration to
deliver a similar solution
increasing installation and support
complexity
modern architecture automation anywhere
provides efficient java based
microservice architecture
ensuring scalability reducing the cost
of infrastructure and maintenance
ui path on the other hand built on a
legacy window workflow foundation
with the last update released in 2012
the scalability is slow
and difficult due to lack of modularity
ease of use in automation anywhere the
easy to use platform enables the regular
employees
to create their own automation but
uipath is targeted towards the developer
community
and needs more intervention from it and
development team
most secure and compliant automation
anywhere
provides the best in-class security
standard whereas uipath
has incomplete security certifications
that create business and compliance risk
easier to scale automation anywhere
quickly scales to thousands of bots in
front and back office
no matter the type attended unattended
or document processing
ui paths architecture unable to scale
horizontally
and required to duplication of entire
application
for every service expansion quicker roi
in automation anywhere the modern
microservices architecture
enables a platform to scale both
vertically and horizontally
delivering faster roi in ui path
with most deployments limited to a
single digit large scale deployments
become difficult
explain javascript package in automation
anywhere
the javascript package contains actions
that allow a bot to run javascript
on windows linux and unix-based devices
these activities can launch javascript
the javascript includes the following
actions open
this action opens a javascript file in
automation anywhere
close this action closes the session and
specifies the same session name from the
open action
run javascript action runs a function
within the java script
now let us look at some of the advanced
level automation anywhere interview
questions
how to write inline scripts using python
command in automation anywhere
step 1 create a new bot and step 2
drag and drop the following actions that
is python script
open execute function and python script
close
finally add a message box to display the
result variable
let us go to the automation in our
control room
so i have already created a bot
i'll open that bot
search for the python script package
from the python script package drag and
drop the open function
in the open function specify the session
name if you already have an existing
file on your device
then select the import existing device
and enter the file path
or you can enter the input manually so i
have entered the input manually
in which i have defined a function
function which i have named it as name
and i have called an argument called
string
and i have returned that argument so
select the python runtime
version in my device python version 3 is
installed so i have selected the three
and then drag and drop the python script
in this enter the session name and enter
the name of function to be executed
as you can see here in the previous open
action
i have entered the function name as name
so and enter this in the python script
action enter the
name of the function then argument to
the function
create a variable so i have created a
variable and named it as
python variable so and i have assigned
the value to this variable
and i have assigned a value called
thanks to this variable
and then in the display message enter
the
variable which you had created so we had
created
the variable python variable and assign
it
so enter the variable just second
so select the variable and then close
the message box after 10 seconds
then once you open the python script
then we have to close the python script
as well
and the session name should be the same
so for in detail explanation and better
understanding check out
our tutorial on automation anywhere
using python
check out this video in which i have
explained all the steps in detail
how python is used in automation anyway
so now
we'll click on save and click on save
and run this
downloading dependencies downloading
dependencies
and here you go the message from the bot
is being displayed as
thanks this was the value which we had
assigned to the variable
and the window will close in 10 seconds
how to create a credential in automation
anywhere
step one navigate to bots and go to the
credentials section
then enter the credential name and
description for the configured
credential
then enter the attribute name and supply
the description for the attribute
then select the external keyword then
select input
standard or user provided set the
security and click create credential
let's go to the automation anywhere and
create a credential
in the control room go to manage
in the manage you can see credentials
click on credentials
and if you if you go here you can see
create credential
click on create credential enter the
credential name
enter the credential description which
is optional
then scroll down and enter the attribute
name
whatever the attribute you want enter
the attribute name and enter the
description which is optional
and provide the input either you can
keep the input standard or user provided
when you keep the input as user provided
when the credential is added to the
locker
an email will be sent to the consumer of
the locker so you will receive an email
but we don't want to receive an email so
we'll keep it as standard
and enter the value so enter
the value of the attribute which you are
creating and you can keep the value it
must
when you keep it masked the value gets
encrypted usually we use it for
passwords
when you enter the password we encrypt
the value that is why we select mask
and you can create the attribute like
this and if you want you can
create multiple attributes click on plus
and you can create the multiple
attributes
once you have created the attributes
then when you scroll up
here you can see this option create
credential this option will get
enabled then you click on create
credential and the credential gets
created
this is how you create a credential how
to set up a locker and assign
credentials
step 1 create and assign roles step 2
create a credential
and step 3 create a locker so it is very
simple
let's go to the control room
go to the credential sections in this
you can see the lockers option here
go to lockers and click on create
locker once you click on create blocker
enter the locker name enter the
description
so in the credentials whatever
credentials you have created will be
shown here
so i have already deposited this
credential in the locker that is why it
is
disabled for me so once you have created
the credential
check this box select the credential and
click here to
deposit this credential in the locker
once that is done go to the owners
and select the owner so your
owner email address will be shown here
select that email address and
deposit that in the locker once that is
done go to managers
this is optional and this manager is not
enabled in the community edition
and even the participants this is also
not enabled in the community edition
so skip these two steps and go to
consumers and in consumers
check the community edition user and
deposit that in the locker
once this much is done you can see this
option create locker
this option will get enabled so click on
create
locker and the locker will get created
check out my previous video on
automation anywhere excel operations
in which i have shown how to create a
credential and how to create a locker in
detail
create a bot to login web page using
automation anywhere
actions using the above question are as
follows
we will use the browser package that
contains actions
that enable you to download files find
broken lines and launch a website
it contains a capture action from the
recorder package
to capture an interaction with the user
interface object
such as text box button table etc
let's go to the automation anywhere
control room and create a bot to log in
web page using automation anywhere
so this is the login bot which i have
already created
you can check out our automation
anywhere tutorial in which i have
detailedly explained each step
how to create a bot to login inside any
web page
so basically in this we are using a
browser action
in the browser action we will open it in
a new window
will browse in the google chrome you can
select whichever you want
for now i have selected google chrome
and select the link to open
so in this project i will login inside
the simply learns web page
so for that i have selected the link
that is the
link in the simply lens so go to the
simply lens web page
go to the login page
and i have copied this link of the login
page
so i've pasted the link to open here
then i have used the recorder package
from the recorder package i have used
the capture action in which
in the first action i'll capture the
email address in the second
capture action i'll capture the password
in the third capture action
i'll click on the login button so i have
captured this three action
so let us save and click on run
here you go it has opened the webpage in
the new
window so entering the email address
password and clicking on the login
button
and it has logged it inside the simply
learns web page
and your bot has run successfully
create a bot to merge two data tables
from a different excel sheets into a new
sheet
so to merge two data tables together in
a single data table
in automation anywhere we use merge
action from the data table package
so let's go to automation anywhere so i
have the two excel files file one and
file two so in file one
i have 6 rows of employee names and
salaries
in file 2 i have 5 rows of salary
of salaries and employee names so i'll
merge both these tables into a new excel
sheet
so for that let us go to
let us go to the automation anywhere
control room you can check out our
automations anywhere excel operations
videos
in which we have explained all the excel
operations and actions in detail
in step one i have selected the file one
that is i have opened the excel file one
and assigned it to get multiple cell
actions
and close the file similarly in step 2 i
have opened the file
to and similarly assign the get multiple
cells
and close the file tool then from the
data table package
from the data table package i have used
this merged
action this merges two data tables
together in a single data table
so i have used this so i have used this
action
so i'll disable the
other actions click on save and run the
file
so the excel bot is running and a new
file name
named as result will be created on the
desktop
so the bot has run successfully let us
go to the desktop
and see the result file which got
created let us open this file
and here you can see both the data
tables have been merged into a new excel
files
six first six rows from the file one and
the next five rows from the file door
have been merged into a single data
table
how to remove duplicate rows from a data
table in automation anywhere
to remove duplicate rows from the data
table use remove duplicate rows action
from the data table package
as you can see in this data table there
there is a duplicate row named
john which is repeated twice
so let us go to automation anywhere and
perform
action to remove this duplicate rows so
let us close this
so if you go to the data table action
here you can see remove duplicate rows
so double click on this and then you
will get the loop double click on remove
duplicate rows
and in do remove duplicate rows select
the data table
name so i'm selecting the data variable
which i had created
so just specify the data table name and
the automation anywhere will remove the
duplicate rows
so let us click on save and
let us run
here you can see the excel bot is
running it is opening both the excel
files
it is checking for duplicate rows and
your bot has successfully run
so let us close this and go to desktop
and here you can see the duplicate row
has been deleted
so there was one more duplicate row with
the name john
so that row has been deleted so this is
how you delete duplicate rows
in automation from the excel from the
data table the last question
how to sort data in the data table using
automation anywhere
to sort data in a data table automation
anywhere provides a sort action from the
data table package
so if you look at this data table you
can see the salaries column
the salaries is not sorted so we'll sort
the salary scholar
in the descending order the employee
with the highest salary
will be at the top and the employee with
the lowest salary will be at the bottom
so let's close this
and we'll enable this sort data action
so
what you have to do is select sort data
action from the data table package
once you select this specify the data
table name
and the column name so we want to sort
the column salaries
then select the order in which you want
to sort we'll sort it in the descending
order
click on save and click on run
here you can see deploying to the
computer downloading the dependencies
and the bot is running
so your bot has run successfully let's
go to desktop
and open the file results
and here you can see the data is sorted
in the descending order
the employee with the highest salary is
at the top
similarly in the decreasing order the
employee with the lowest salary is a
demand so let's begin by understanding
who is an rpa developer
now generally speaking an rpa developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create and optimize workflow
processes
however this is a relatively new career
path and many organizations formal
titles for rpa developers differ
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect
but no matter the title the role of a
successful rpa developer
involves to design develop and implement
rpa systems
in order to automate a business process
an rpa developer will be required to
create workflow diagrams
and strategically document the
implementation he is also responsible
for bug fixes
so coding skills are important now in
order to be a successful
rpa developer you must have the ability
to navigate various appropriate
technologies
such as uipath or automation anywhere
next up is rpa growth projections
now looking at the curve both rpa
software and services
increased by huge amounts between 2016
and 2020 and beyond
according to nexus day research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact
of about five to seven trillion us
dollars for the year 2025
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute up to
nine percent of the global workforce
now any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions
will boost their capabilities and save
money and time without
aid now that we've established that rpa
has a steep growth curve
let's look at the rpa job roles that you
should look out for
we have the rpa developer senior rpa
developer
rpa process architect rpa developer
senior consultant
project manager lead developer business
analyst
and rpa data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an rpa developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills now planning is a crucial phase
in any development life cycle
the rpa developer regardless of the
designation should possess the aptitude
to ensure strategic planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of rpa systems
this also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
and cater to the needs accordingly
is crucial analytical skills are also
important to predict or identify
potential bugs and errors and rectify
them
now this skill is especially required if
you're involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict
any outages and equip the entire unit to
overcome
any unforeseen interruptions from the
business perspective as well
problem solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction
of tasks experience in any programming
language
such as c c plus plus python ruby
java or dot net is also important
hands-on experience in rpa tools and
cognitive platforms
such as blueprism automation anywhere ui
path
open spam etc is necessary
communication skills are pivotal for any
organization
the developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas
he should also be confident to raise
concerns and be as transparent as
possible
in the long run this only proves to be
helpful to the organization
lastly we have exposure to sql now
experience with database be it sql
or nosql is highly preferred it's always
an added advantage if you have the
knowledge about accessing and managing
databases
next up we have rpa developer salaries
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location
your experience and also the designation
now in the u.s here are the job salaries
and
the roles according to glassdoor an rpa
developer in the us
earns around 76 000 us dollars per year
the nrp developer senior consultant
earns around 99 000 us dollars per year
an rpa process architect earns an
average salary of 95
000 us dollars and the senior rpa
developer earns an average salary of 92
000 us dollars
an rpa project manager earns around 73
000 us dollars per annum
an rpa lead developer earns an average
salary of 99 000 us dollars per annum
an rpa business analyst earns around 68
000 us dollars per annum
and the data analyst earns around 62 000
us dollars per annum moving on to india
the average salary of an rpa developer
is around 5 lakhs 98 000 rupees
that of a senior consultant a senior
arcade developer and an rpa lead
developer is around 14 lakhs per annum
and the average value of an rpa business
analyst is around 5 lakhs 40 000 rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an rpa developer
now this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs
first up is your general information
like name phone number and your email id
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths
you can also mention the objective as to
why you're applying and what you're
looking for in the organization
you can include your linkedin profile
link and your github link
one look at your linkedin profile is
enough for anybody to gather
all the information necessary so make
sure that it's updated
moving on you could mention your
experience now here you would have to
mention
the names of your previous organizations
along with your designation
and the tenure you could also include
your key responsibilities in these
organizations
along with your responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received
in your organizations next up is your
educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from and is required that you
have a degree in computer science
you can also go ahead and mention your
gpa
the next section is skills now this is
pretty crucial in the technical skills
section you could mention about
different rpa tools that you've worked
on
if you're good at a particular
programming language go ahead and
mention that as well as mentioned
earlier
any experience in database management is
an added advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills you could mention any
extracurricular activities that you're
proud of
some soft skills that you feel worth
mentioning can be added in this section
mentioning the languages that you know
can also boost your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume
first let's understand who an rpa
developer
is now generally speaking
an rpa developer is someone who works
cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts
to create and optimize workflow
processes
now however this is a relatively new
career path and many
organizations formal titles for rpa
developers differ
now other similar positions may use
titles like process designer
or automation architect but no matter
the title
the role of a successful rpa developer
requires specific skills and best
practices like documentation and
planning
now in order to automate a business
process an rpa developer will be
required to create workflow diagrams
and strategically document the process
prior to implementation
now he may also be responsible for
testing and bug fixes
so coding skills are also important
now in order to become a successful rpa
developer
you must have the ability to navigate
through appropriate technologies
such as uipath or automation anywhere
however there are a few prerequisites to
become an rpa developer
well it's not very hard but a little
prep is necessary
so let's go through them one by one
first up is strategic planning now
planning is a critical phase in any
development life cycle
the rpa developer regardless of the
designation
should possess the aptitude to ensure
strategic planning
strategic planning basically includes
design
development and implementation of rpa
systems
this also helps streamline the entire
business
to optimize the efficiency
next up is analytical skills now again
as the name suggests it's crucial to
analyze the information
and make decisions to maximize your
efficiency
right now these are skills that one
develops when they're exposed to it
so over a period of time you're going to
develop these skills
not to worry about it now
next up is problem solving skills now
these skills are again crucial to
predict
any potential outages and equip the
entire unit
to overcome any unforeseen interruptions
from the business perspective as well
problem solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction of tasks
experience in programming languages like
say c plus plus
c python ruby java is also crucial
next up is hands-on experience and rpe
tools
and cognitive platforms like blue prism
automation anywhere
redwood open span etc
now other general skills include
communication skills as well
now this is pivotal for any organization
now the developer should be outspoken
and should articulate new ideas
now that you're familiar with the skills
required let's look at the job
description for an rpa developer
and some of his responsibilities so
here's a screenshot of the job
advertisement
posted by ibm
as mentioned some of the
responsibilities include
crafting automation process solutions
coding and scripting in
any of the automation tools configuring
new automation using core automation
tools
communicating with business analysts and
clients building and documenting the
best
supporting the operational teams during
any rollout phases
supporting existing processes and
implementing change requirements
and successfully managing any sort of
issues so if you're aspiring to become
an rpa developer
then these are some of the job
responsibilities that you will have to
readily take up
if you're still wondering if this field
has scope for development in the coming
years
let me clarify it for you so let's go
ahead and look at the rpa growth
projections and salary
according to gartner robotic process
automation software
grew up by 63 in 2018 making it the
fastest growing segment of the global
enterprise software market
now the growth curve has also been
steadily increasing since 2016
and continues beyond 2020. now it is
also predicted that rpa will touch more
than 230 million knowledge workers
which constitute up to say nine percent
of the global workforce
now any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing
high volume high transaction functions
can totally benefit from rpa
so if you're still skeptical about
picking up rpa i hope this clarified it
for you
so moving on to salaries in the u.s the
average sanity of an rpa developer
is around 76 000 us dollars
the average site of an rpa developer in
india is around 6 lakh rupees per annum
so the companies that are greatly hiring
for rpa developers
are ibm capturing emphasis
volvo and accenture among others
moving on here are a few tips to
kickstart your rta career
so let's go ahead and look at them one
by one
first up is to choose your rpa platforms
now all rpa tools have graphical user
interface
or guis but it's really helpful to
understand the underlying technology now
this comes in extremely handy when the
developer has to create more
complex c personalized or advanced bots
so if you are a python developer then
you can start off by
working with argos labs so this allows
the developers to build plugins with
almost no effort from the existing
python code
so if you're a python developer then you
can start off by working with argos labs
now this really allows developers to
build plugins with literally no effort
and if you're a dot net developer then
you can start off with uipath or
automation anywhere's community editions
so if you're a java developer then you
can start off with automation anywhere
and if you're a developer with no
experience then you can
begin with any of the leading rpa
providers
now tip number two is to start building
there are plenty of free materials and
guides to help you begin your rpa
journey
so some of the famous or well-known rpa
tools
are blue prism work fusion ui path
automation anywhere
etc so just start working on them
tip number three is build your github
repository
no matter how small or simple you think
your project is
go ahead and put it on your github
repository this totally adds credibility
to your profile
even if you're attending interviews one
look at your github repository is going
to make them realize how good of a
developer you are
tip number four is to take up
freelancing projects
now again to start off you can take up
say non-paid or even low paid projects
some of the websites that you could look
up are upwork
freelancer troll answer people per hour
so tip number five is to start a blog
now having your own blog
will add credibility to your profile no
matter how
less you've worked on any projects you
can go ahead and type in
all the information you want recruiters
can also have a glance at your profile
you're definitely gonna get some extra
points for this
tip number six is to ensure you update
your resume and profile
now keep your resume and profiles
updated on all job portals like
linkedin indeed simply hired and monster
so these were some simple tips to help
you become an rpa developer
there are several rpa courses that you
can take up but if you're looking for a
well curated concise syllabus
then you can head to our official
website and type in
rpa so let's do that
you can go ahead and search for rpa
now a list of courses will appear and
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and choose the appropriate one
you can also go through the overview to
understand what's covered in the course
so with that we have come to end of this
automation anywhere full course
if you enjoyed watching it make sure to
hit the subscribe button
and press the bell icon to never miss an
update
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply then